bonsoir François Baayou bonsoir vous
avez dit votre soulagement après votre
relaxe dans l'affaire des assistants
parlementaires européens vous pouvez
vraiment être soulagé alors que vos
camarades et votre parti ont été
condamnés quand vous avez subi 7 années
vous rendez compte ce que c'est 7 années
d'accusation que le tribunal déclare
infondé il il dit au bénéfice du doute
parce qu'il n'a pas de
preuve oui il est
ce n'est pas qu'il n'y ait pas de preuve
c'est que on ne peut pas trouver de
preuve parce que ce n'est pas vrai je
dis cette même phrase depuis le premier
jour et c'est extraordinaire on vous
accuse pendant des années puis le jour
où vous êtes relaxé on dit bon alors on
dit attention mais c'est parce qu'il n'y
a pas de preuve bien sûr il y a pas de
preuve le le ce que je disais moi
surtout c'est votre partie a été
condamné parz-m non non
oui il il faut peut-être rappeler ce que
c'est cette affaire on dit les
assistants parlementaire on n'est pas le
seul parti politique comme vous savez il
y en a d'autres
euh le parti de Marine Le Pen le parti
de Jean-Luc Mélenchon qui sont inquiétés
c'est d'ailleurs bizarre parce que c'est
toujours ceux qui sont minoritaires qui
sont inquiétés
mais on peut y réfléchir non je
j'emploie jamais des mots de cet ordre
qu'est-ce que ça signifie et donc les
assistants parlementaires euh nous
étions accusés d'avoir fait travailler
des assistants parlementaires pour le
parti politique alors il faut d'abord
dire combien d'assistants parlementaires
nous avons eu pendant cette période je
dis ça parce qu'évidemment tout le monde
a vu les gros titres quand on était
accusé et puis le jour où vous êtes
relaxé alors il y a plus de gros titres
du tout il y a plus on a fait un sujet
et on vous et on vous accueès et c'est
très bien donc on peut on peut expliquer
ça et donc combien d'assistants sont
mises en cause on a eu pendant cette
période 131 assistant parlementaires nos
députés européens 131 et il y en a
6 qui sont mis en cause mais c'est la
pratique qui est
dénoncé salari du Parlement euré qui
dans V à Paris non pardonnez-moi de
vous contredire parce que le le jugement
a dit ou et même les magistrat ont dit
bon on n pas de preuve qu'ils ont
travaillé pour les partis mais
l'essentiel pour nous je je reprends la
phrase exacte du président qu'ils ai
travaillé pour les partis ou qu'il soit
allé jouer au golf c'est sa phrase
exacte ça ça nous intéresse pas
or de quoi étions-nous accusés pas de
les avoir envoyés jouer au golf de les
avoir utilisé pour travailler pour le
parti et et ceci non seulement n'est pas
vrai mais je ni absolument qu'il y ait
eu la moindre chose de cet ordre là on
et donc vous dénoncez cette condamnation
de votre parti non je cette condamnation
d'abord c'est une condamnation avec
surcis je vous rappelleut faut peut-être
dire les choses voilà est-ce que cette
relaxe vous ouvre les portes du
ministère de l'Éducation nationale que
vous connaissez bien d'abord j'ai été
ministre de l'éducation nationale je
suis entré au ministère de l'éducation
nationale les gens étaient très heureux
à l'époque il y a 31 ans alors c'est une
jolie histoire à raconter c'est mieux
qu'Alexandre Duma Alex duum avait écrit
20 ans après là vous là vous m'invitez à
écrire 30 je vous invite parce que on
entend cette rumeur est-ce qu'elle est
fondée non je pense qu'il y a un très
grand trouble dans l'éducation nationale
pas depuis ce mois-ci depuis seulement
depuis
l'Arée depuis des années des années euh
et que c'est un secteur pour moi vous
savez à quel point je J j'y crois à quel
point je je donnerai pour pour que on
retrouve le le morale l'équilibre la
l'envie d'enseigner sans trouble dans
notre pays et la réussite de
l'enseignement
doncz bien on n'est pas dans la
formation du gouvernement mais je je
pense que c'est probablement le sujet le
plus important ou un des sujets les plus
importants que nous ayons à à à régler
ou en pose cette question parce que vous
avez dû quitter le gouvernement à cause
de cette affaire l'affaire dont nous
parlions est-ce que vous aimeriez plutôt
que d'être dans les conseils être dans
l'action et rentrer de nouveau dans le
gouvernement je pense que quand on est
un un citoyen engagé on aime agir mais
ayant la responsabilité du
plan en effet j'ai l'impression
d'influer sur l'action peut-être pas
assez c'est pas seulement depuis ces
dernières années parce que que quand
jean- Monet était commissaire au Plan
vous savez le
l'immense
personnalité qui a eu la responsabilité
du plan après la guerre il disait
exactement la même chose que je viens de
dire on peut agir davantage sur l'action
et il y a en France euh profond malaise
sur l'action publique et sur
l'organisation de l'action publique mais
que pesez-vous aujourd'hui au sein au
pouvoir vous avez vous étiez l'alliés av
51 députés vous oui mais au sein au sein
de l'exécutif je vous est que votre voix
porte encore auprès de du président Ben
peut-être vous m'inviteriez pas si
c'était pas le cas j'imagine que vous
choisissez les sujets de vos interviews
en se demandant si ça peut intéresser
vos
auditeurs vousz RER au gouvernement ça
compte le gouvernement n'est pas
forméé mais je n'écarte jamais rien le
le principe pour
moi précisément parce que vous êtes
engagé c'est de ne jamais rien écarter
merci beaucoup François ou d'être venue
sur notre plateau c'est la fin de ce
journal